today magnus carlsen won a brilliancy
already deemed one of his best chess
games and a
positional chess masterpiece as often
happens after a setback like his loss to
due to yesterday
magnus came out in force reminding all
of his would-be critics
why he's been number one for over a
decade
fetishev opens the game here with pawn
d4 magnus responds with knight f6 and we
get c4
and g6 now already i think that this is
indicating that there's going to be some
interesting and uncompromising play
from both players they came to play
they're not looking for a short draw
as for example happened in the other
game karjakin
vs duda now that sentiment that the
players are playing in an uncompromising
fashion is
only increased by the next move pawn to
h4
from fedexaev now this might
look like an amateurish move i'm
certainly very used to club players
liking to advance their ancient apons as
soon as someone fianchetto's a bishop
but this is actually high theory and one
can point to the games of alpha zero and
lila chess zero where these neural
network engines
have shown the strength of advancing the
ancient apons
in many many different positions
unfortunately for fetishaev by the end
of this game it is going to be
magnus that is playing very much in an
alpha zero
s style now after pawn to h4 we get
bishop g7
knight c3 d6 e4
knight c6 and a very committal decision
pawn to
d5 advancing and gaining space but
giving up the dark squares
now of course fedesev is a
great player and he knows exactly what
he's doing with a move like pawn to d5
and one should by no means
consider this move a mistake but one
should still appreciate i think
the ramifications of a very committal
decision early on like this
and one should pay attention to how
magnus tries to use
the weaknesses that are offered up to
him the imbalances that favor him to his
advantage
and here the control of the dark squares
is going to be a big
part of his game from here on out we get
95 now
bishop e2 looking to play pawn to h5
and pawn to h5 of course magnus shuts
that down
that's very much in magnus's style and
he's going to be doing a lot throughout
this game to shut down tedisev's play
bishop f4 castles it might be tempting
here to consider the capture here on e5
because
well you do double black's pawns and you
also
kind of make this bishop bad but you're
giving up the bishop pair
and after for example knight f3 which
seems very natural
pawn to e6 will fix the pawns white is
actually not
in a position to capture here because of
discoveries from moving this night
so this is actually a better position
for black
after castles a fetishive actually plays
knight f3
and now magnus plays knight takes f3
at this point we again very early in the
game
get an extremely committal decision from
fedesaith
pawn takes f3 now
the computer considers this move at
least my computer considers this move
equivalent to bishop takes f3
and it considers both moves to be pretty
balanced
it gives a near equal evaluation while
in this case after bishop takes f3 i
think that that equal evaluation
indicates a lot of safety for both
players although the game can go in many
different directions
that is not what is indicated after pawn
takes f3
this is now a very imbalanced position
and i think that most players would much
rather have
the black side the
compromises here in the pawns are very
hard to fix there's
very little flexibility in white's pawn
structure from here on out white is
hoping to win
based on very active piece play maybe
use of the
g-file and that never really comes to
fruition
of course against someone who wasn't the
world chess champion maybe fedesaiv
could have shown the value in a move
like pawn takes f3
but in this game any benefits to this
pawn capture
never really make themselves felt and
all of the
all of the downsides are going to be
hampering fetisev later in the game
we get pawn c6 queen d2
and there's obviously the idea of bishop
h6 here which you'd love to play
after pawn takes d5 and pawn takes d5
magnus shuts that down with the very
thematic
king to h7 controlling the h6 square
pawn to a4 an interesting idea that's
expanding on the queen side and also
looking at
some rook lefts which could introduce a
lot of dynamicism
into the white position knight d7 and
a5 f5 the f-file
is already making itself felt and the
pressure
on the f3 pawn here is significant
rook to a3 that rook lift that we talked
about
knight e5 again taking aim at the
doubled pawns
bishop e3 and in this position what
fedesev
really wants to do on the next turn is
play
pawn to f4 attacking the knight on e5
evicting it and justifying all of his
creative play if white can play
pawn to f4 then white has a really good
chance to be
better this is exactly what i was
talking about when i said that maybe
against
a player who didn't play quite as well
as magnus fetiseiv could have justified
all of his creative and committal play
but he
is playing against magnus and magnus is
sort of one step ahead
and once again magnus stops
this idea in its tracks pawn to f4
a beautiful pawn sacrifice for magnus
very thematic it keeps the f-file open
it stops pawn to f4
from white and it introduces some very
concrete tactical ideas
including an exchange sacrifice after
f4 we get bishop takes f4
and here you could already think about
the sacrifice of the exchange here
commentators were already saying what
about rook takes f4
but magnus plays bishop d7 first
and after looking at it a little bit
this just seems super instructive to me
and i really enjoy this move
because black's position has improved
enormously
with bishop d7 obviously the bishop
is developed it's now influencing both
sides of the board there are some new
ideas like
maybe pawn to b5 in some cases the rooks
and the queen are now communicating
there's access to the c file etc bishop
d7 just does
a lot with a simple move it's clearly
improving black's position
and a big question for white is do you
have a move
that is of equal value that also
improves your position as much as bishop
d7
just improved mine and it seems like the
answer is no
which is just a great indication of why
it was better to keep the tension
and not sacrifice the exchange yet
because fetisheive now plays the move
knight to d1 and it's hard to suggest
anything better
this move now defends the f3 pawn with
the rook
of course the knight was blocking the
rook a moment ago and now there's the
idea of
moving this bishop out of the way and
then you could push the f-pawn and
things are totally different
white's position is getting a lot of
freedom but
now magnus plays his prepared exchange
sacrifice which of course
fedesev also saw coming rook takes
f4 beautiful move
you know i could see some saying that
two exclamation
marks is too much for this move this
kind of exchange sacrifice is a very
established idea and
both magnus and fetisev and all the
grandmaster commentators were like hey
this idea is there
but this is a brilliant game the
execution on the idea
of this exchange sacrifice and the
domination of the dark squares and so
many other squares
all stem from this move so if not here
where are you going to recognize
the brilliance of this game i think this
just
is you know recognition of the whole
concept of the game
rook takes f4 queen takes f4 bishop h6
and the queen has to fall back on this
diagonal which is one of the big
problems
in the position the queen just doesn't
have anywhere good to go
and is getting kind of buried on the
king side
after queen g3 we see queen to f8
firming up that control of f4 and
getting ready to bring the bishop
into f4 knight e3 bishop
f4 and queen g2 now
at this point i should mention that uh
you know there were commentaries
at this point you know looking at the
computer evaluation which is still
saying like 0.0
which is really good whenever you see
someone sacrifice like an exchange and a
pawn or a lot of material and the
computer says hey you still have full
compensation
you should feel very optimistic about
your chances but
there's discussion about is this
exchange sacrifice justified and i saw
any scary
comment on twitter you know anticipating
you know later commentary from magnus
and say basically that this is just
strategically one that's probably too
much and one never knows with anishigiri
how serious he is when he's tweeting and
here he's not even tweeting in his own
voice
but the way the game goes it it almost
feels like it's strategically won
uh from here i also saw yon napomneshi
comment
that you know it's a lot harder to play
on a 4x4 board instead of an 8x8 board
and the course of the game
really bears that out you know this is
the only piece
in this position that's not playing in
this square for
white whereas black just is controlling
the whole board and that problem
is only accentuated as we go forth from
here
so in this position we get rook over to
c8
um controlling the c file and rook c3
now one comment um
i'm not quite sure i think it was anand
and commentary
but one comment was you know when you
see an exchange sacrifice like this one
of the big questions
is can the rooks get active if they can
get active then the exchange sacrifice
might not work
and a famous example of that is um
is anan vs carlson in the world
championship
and onon sacrificed an exchange that
looked really tempting
but carlson activated his rooks and it
just didn't work
in this game though the rooks never
really get active it makes so much sense
to exchange off the rook because it's
very active here
you don't want to allow the rook to
remain on the c file but
this really does lock white into a
position in which
there aren't really any active pieces
and
the brooklyn h1 never really gets into
the game
rook takes c3 pawn takes c3 and
the queen runs over to c8 um a beautiful
square
fedecia plays pawn to c4 it seems like
everything is defended
but on the other hand everything is also
restricted
everything is blocked in here another
nice point um about
queen c8 is that your queen and bishop
now make a battery and if white castles
you can play bishop h3
and you can pick up an exchange now
we get b5 we get the ompassant capture
here
actually i should make another point
here um
after b5 uh and
a takes b6 a takes b6 yeah right here
right here
this maybe was one of fedesiev's best
outs
um here what if you do give the exchange
back
now later on there was a lot of
discussion about when was the right time
to sacrifice the exchange and
maybe earlier is better here you do
allow bishop to h3 and magnus needs to
go for it he's not in a position once
the rook starts thinking about getting
active
to continue to play down the exchange so
bishop h3
queen h1 and bishop takes f1 king takes
f1
here magnus definitely still has full
compensation for the exchange
but one of the biggest problems in
white's position that rook on h1
a problem that doesn't really get
resolved is gone
so that was definitely worthy of
consideration it's tough to give back
material
but when you do need to sometimes
earlier is better than later
so after uh the trade on b6 though
fedesev plays queen g1
now there was a beautiful line pointed
out here by donya naraditsky in the
commentary
here he mentioned the possibility of b5
now the engine here is saying knight g2
and it's still very unclear
but if white captures on b5 the line
that donya pointed out is queen c1 check
knight back to d1 and here queen d2
check
king f1 queen takes e2 check
beautiful a queen sacrifice leading to a
spectacular minor piece mate king takes
e2
bishop takes b5 forces the king back to
e1
and knight takes f3 checkmate
that would have been a stunning finish
the way the game progressed is beautiful
too but that would have been
that that would have been immortal game
territory like i think everyone had been
like this is magnus's best game of all
time no question no argument
we all just agree now in any case
after queen g1 we actually see queen to
a8 which is a better move than b5
unfortunately also queen a6 was good
but we had to show that you know really
beautiful
um beautiful checkmate with the queen
sacrifice
king f1 the queen infiltrates queen a2
and here we get knight g2 at this point
there was some criticism from some who
said hey queen b1 check is stronger than
queen a1 check was that was played in
the game
and the reason is that the queen here on
b1 is supporting some lines
where the c pawn is breaking and then
advancing
whereas on a1 it's not controlling for
example the c2 square and that's
you know maybe a little weaker than what
was played in the game
after knight g2 queen a1 check but the
difference is not very large magnus
still has a huge advantage and the main
idea
is just that he controls everything
we're approaching zug's wing
in this position knight e1 queen b2
knight g2 the united is trying to
shuffle queen c1 check tonight goes back
to e1
and queen to d2 at this point the knight
can no longer continue shuffling
really white is almost out of moves at
this point it's a huge problem the
bishop can't move the rook can't move
unless you're ready to get back the
exchange and then magnus probably isn't
even going to take it
and the queen has no scope it's
it's dire for white in this position if
knight g2 you try to continue hey i'm
just going to shuffle the knight back
and forth and back and forth and back
and forth
then knight d3 is a beautiful finish
bishop takes
queen takes here king over to e1 you
have bishop d2
king d1 and the final bishop introduces
itself with bishop
a4 this bishop is a beautiful spectator
but it's been a bit of a spectator but
here it gets into the game
anyway after queen d2 we see queen g2
king g7 this is just like announcing
zug's wing here i'm just going to start
maneuvering with my king
and you can't move anything and it's
true magnus's control here is just
an incredible thing a thing of beauty
rook g1
king over to f8 queen h1
and pawn to e6 this is going to
just crack the white position open
because after the exchange here and if
you take on e6 and the bishop is getting
involved in an attack on c4 here
if you take on e6 i'm sorry after after
the capture on d5 i mean
you're either getting a situation where
there's now all of a sudden a past b
pawn or you're giving a situation where
the bishop can get into the game so
e6 is the break that really brings home
you know i'm not just sitting here i'm
actually making progress and you can't
hold
rook g3 please take my exchange no
i don't want your exchange pawn takes d5
bishop f5 as said the bishop
is getting introduced here rook g1
king f7 rook g3 and
knight d7 a very nice move the knight
has
among many other ideas the idea of
coming around here to b3 and then over
to c1
and the bishop is trapped after knight
d7 fetishev plays
rook g5 just insisting on the capture of
the rook and magnus finally obliges but
after bishop takes
pawn takes knight e5 fetishev resigns
in this position he can't move anything
magnus can pick off pawns at will
he now has a past h-pawn as well
it's it's just completely over and
wow just what an achievement by magnus
beautiful game incredible exchange
sacrifice
so many fine points throughout the game
unquestionably a positional mag
masterpiece some have called it magnus's
immortal zugswing game and that seems
entirely fair beautiful game from magnus
carlson for more videos from chess.com
and to be alerted of our live coverage
of the fiji world cup
and the fiji world championship and so
many more events be sure to hit that
subscribe button
[Music]
you